hi my name is markiplier
and this is three scary games don't
worry
i know what you're thinking if there's
gonna be some kind of a spook
that there's gonna be a scare there
won't be any of that
none at all it's just you
and me and lixian
he's here somewhere don't worry
he always has the best of intentions
so let's get right into it
this is there are ghosts in these stalls
i think i'm upside down lixian flip the
screen
yeah that's the bottom of a bathroom
stall there's something written over
there i don't know what it is though
oh
okay
oh well i'm pooping that's good
nothing to worry about
oh what the heck is that a poop butt did
i just collect the poop butt
i collected a poop butt
probably fine okay i don't know why
there's candles in the bathroom
but they definitely are
oh hey buddy
how you doing over there
you like jazz is there something else
that i'm supposed to see
i don't see any other symbols
oh maybe under there oh
gotcha okay
all right good yeah fine
that's fine okay good i got that
okay everything's fine
just me and
everything's fine what am i afraid of
open
nailed it nailed that i don't know what
was staring at me from the darkness
oh x x marks the spot
oh oh my god
[Music]
okay yeah all right you got me okay
yeah you got me okay yeah you feel good
about yourself you got me i'm about to
get you
you don't know where it's gonna come you
don't know what is happening look over
there
look over there look at this that's good
i legitimately liked that that was so
short but it was very
very good i did enjoy that i really did
how
this is cut short all right blub blum
oh was to move what was cut short in my
driver my life
seems like i got in a bit of a bit of an
awuga okay well i'm pretty speedy
hello help i've been in a terrible
accident i couldn't have possibly
survived
i might be dead wandering the ether
hello oh
perfect
love the music i love the music
oh this looks safe help help
my legs are broken and my spleen is
ruptured
oh oh
whoa oh
okay i'm into it i'm into it i'm down
this is cool i like it oh wow
hello thank goodness i found this
abandoned house in the middle of nowhere
please call 9-1-1 i'm bleeding
internally
and externally oh physics
did not expect that help help
i moved your boxes for you someone
please
oh wait a minute oh
what is this what could this be
hi hello
how are you good to see you
okay help help
ah shoot did i do that uh sorry about
your voss
i was stumbling from the lack of blood
seems to have caused me to why is it
shimmering i don't like it seems to have
caused my brain to have some minor
hemorrhaging
seems like you need to get your floors
repaired
and you should refrigerate your meat
it'll last
longer oh that's a fun
skull i guess they like to eat the faces
first
it's a good thing i've got the maddest
hops huh
okay
hey hey none of that none of that none
of that
none of that none of that none of that
none of that no no i can't pick up that
box apparently
i'll take this one the next biggest i'm
guessing i must stack but
don't judge me skull don't you look at
me like that
look these boxes are just sitting around
of course i can use them
nailed it i'm a genius anyway
seems like you've got a an infestation
down here
okay sir
madam help me please oh
hey okay oh don't be shy
oh hi
okay i didn't mean to seem like i'm
breaking and entering into your house i
swear i just the wind really picks
things up in here
sorry again i am not trying to seem
threatening
uh yeah i'll go back in the basement
your stair is also a little a little
unsmooth
smash smash smash smish smash
smoosh oh
hello hi oh it's gone
oh it's here oh it's there
okay hope you don't mind i opened your
little basement locker
uh okay you all better watch out i've
got this
very oh what oh god the way i was going
up was really weird
hi yeah yeah
hi yeah it was a fire hazard i had to do
it
oh whoops okay i guess i'm doing that
now
hello hello
okay
[Music]
hey
oh i'm just gonna keep oh god the axe i
don't have the axe anymore
oh no oh
i don't have the axe hello
did i drop it or did he consume it
entirely
sorry you were just so frightening i oh
oh was i supposed to fall down that okay
i might have been supposed to do the
fall down that
oh yeah it seems as though i was
supposed to do the fall down that
ah i've fallen
hello
i wonder if there's an easter egg if you
use the axe on the other door
it's very dark down here smash
smoosh my lightest touch of my calves
they're so strong you will capitulate
in the face of my mighty calves
nice bed very dark
what happened to my old flashlight hello
hi oh good great uh excellent
smash hello this is your room
oh good great nothing to smash in here
okay so all the help me uh a little late
for that
but if you need a hand i can give you
one
[Applause]
hello hi
oh don't mind me just taking this key
are you over here hello
hmm interesting oh very dark
okay and
okay man cheerful
oh boy i know a physics puzzle when i
see it
i'm all about this load this up a little
bit here a little heavier
good all right york
i didn't hey good thing they had some
none of that thank you very much that's
rude that's very
high
hello okay
how you're still here how did you
survive for so long
please
we didn't need all of those people that
monster forced us to kill them
so it could feast upon their corpses we
had no choice
i'm so sorry i love this dialogue it
said that if we didn't it would kill us
and eat us too
but it was just too much we couldn't
take it anymore
i tried to attack it but it overpowered
me my family
i killed them every single one now i'm
the only one left
take that axe over there it's coated in
silver it's only weakness
you have to stop it please do it for my
family i don't know your family why
don't you do it
what are you doing standing here hell
yeah
oh i'm just as crazy as the monster
oh it doesn't work
all right
make bait oh i don't want to
hi yeah okay so i gotta make bait huh
i gotta make some bait of course
hello any bait in here smash
anybody seen any bait what's what's
cooking good looking
oh well that'll do
[Music]
yeah okay all right sure yeah that's
that's fine
that's fine that's normal and fine
hello ah of course that's what the key
is for
splunk uh
okay good leg weird leg
you think that i would use real leg but
apparently not
oh all right
okay oh oh carry this axe with me just
in case
perfect okay hello
oh hello hi how you doing
um you seen any arms around here
no oh perfect i should have left this in
there
i should leave this in there how
convenient for me i thought i would have
to go chop off the arms of that other
dude
there we go
why do i have to do this whoa hey pick
it up
i will get you yeah yeah
yeah yeah
what do you mean i died i was trying to
yum
what i mean i died i was yawn up a storm
i was yawning all over him i was giving
him the yaws
okay i'm gonna just wail on him real
hard
come on pick it up pick it up kill it
i'm trying there you go
take that and that got that and that
there you go what do you think of that
huh what do you think of me what do you
think of all of me
and my axe let me ask you a question ah
you need some axe body spray
axe jokes uh nightmare house two
references nice
[Music]
oh hey hi
very cool music though i like that a lot
that was very fun
that was pretty good why hello there
might i just say it's an absolute
pleasure to meet you
i've seen you around and heard the
greatest things about you
thank you for accepting my party
invitation and agreeing to help out set
up the party
looks like you're the only one who
showed up to this birthday surprise
preparation
but no bother i knew i could count on
you so let's dive right in shall we
oh hold up first just a teensy weensy
tiny little thing see that pop-up on
your screen yeah yeah that one
yes simply click allow please nothing to
worry about
the game just requires you to enable
location tracking you know
like all the best games do nowadays it's
not a big deal
just a formality really
ah hi welcome to surprise party
yeah okay sure whatever i got another
yeah you did it i did it now we can
commence
operation super surprise party super
yeah
first things first can you please help
me gather up all those
useless fools who wouldn't help us break
the party
i mean other guests pretty please should
be relatively easy to find them
sure man jump around a bit come back
once you found them all all right i'll
hop around
oh oh oh litter literally i'm i'm
literally hopping
okay hey hi literal baby over here uh
hey you really should have been it
[Music]
that's probably fine you really should
have been at the party i don't know why
you weren't really pathetic of you for
not
appreciating your friends for who they
are and
and please ignore my pathetic
platforming skills
[Music]
yeah that's normal you disrespect your
friends
you meet your end that's how it goes
very goopy
okay all right hey oh wow yeah yeah
let's go get em yeah
all right this is great
hello i got you all wow
back already that was uh um
unexpectedly quick i'm very efficient i
mean but yeah good for you
yeah and look they're all those losers
who didn't come earlier to help us out
um yeah for your next task uh oh
i could use your help fixing my gif you
see i made this
epic painting it's absolutely
spectacular
right you'll see but unfortunately
something overcame me and i ripped it to
shreds
but so goes the life of an artist this
is where you can step in and save the
day
can you pretty please put my masterpiece
back together you can perfect well i
didn't say anything
i oh um okay all right well this should
be easy
i'm very good at puzzles um
well that's not right well this don't
make any sense at all
i don't know man oh there we go
okay uh is there a way to turn these or
something or
uh am i missing something uh doesn't
seem like i can do it if i can't
turn the picture oh i guess that doesn't
go there oh
that makes sense okay am i stupid oh
oh if yeah if you press space that
wasn't communicated
now it's coming together
[Music]
hey okay there's no need
there's there was no need for that whoa
you fixed my epic painting
i did yeah uh-huh what was i saying
what were you saying nothing you know
just silly gibberish that you certainly
don't need to worry about uh-huh
anywho your next task will be
wait hold up did you turn off your
location tracking
no how dare you disobey me
did i not tell you location tracking is
required to play this game
you insulate fool worthless piece of
oops why yes i do see that you turned
your tracking back on huh
um don't mind my temper no no no plea
please don't leave
i mean we're having so much fun together
uh-huh playing these
games getting this party started yeah
all that's left for you to do now is to
gather up some sweets because
after all what's a birthday party
without sweets
and lucky for you it's raining cats and
dogs outside
no no seriously it's raining cats and
dogs
and gumdrops too could you please catch
enough gumdrops to fill this basket
but be careful of the cats and dogs they
have a sweet tooth and they could eat
some of your precious gumdrops
okay you're away from your problems um
there's another baby
there's another baby in here then one
more and are the cats
are the cats and dogs gonna hit the
ground and oh god okay well oh
uh well all right well at least they're
not splatting it i didn't mean to do
that
it's very uh difficult
this is adorable but a little concerned
oh dang it well this is adorable this is
just
lovely uh-huh so
nice this is i will get your gum
drops
well well well
looks like you did it i didn't you did
it all i did it all
every last thing i did
without a second thought even mm-hmm i
had many say
everything i asked of you mm-hmm
congratulations
thank you now as promised
it's time for the surprise alex
surprise birthday party well no
actually there's been a change of plans
we see this is quite the opposite of a
celebration of life party this
this is our celebration for the very
real
ending of yours oh good played the game
so well enabling us to track your
location
giving us time fully immersed distracted
such easy easy prey
we knew from the moment we laid eyes on
you
that you would never catch on to what
was actually happening
you didn't even notice during that last
game we already
found you we were already here
thank you for playing the game and thank
you for
trusting me because you know
you really shouldn't have
[Music]
all right so the thing about it is
i can tell that they they put some work
into that and they were you know they
were
trying to make something interesting the
problem is it was so obvious from the
get-go
like it was too heavy-handed it made a
lot of the quote-unquote scares
like fall flat it would have been nicer
if like it took itself seriously
from the start instead of being like
you're so
stupid you didn't even think about the
fact that we're gonna
kill you it's just like i feel like it
would have just been a lot
more immersive because i like the the
it's cutesy on the surface but it's not
in the game like that's that's a cool
thing but you got to do it right
hello sam so many people have complained
about the weird occurrences of sound in
this
area and i thought you would be the
perfect plumber to fix
the siren since you haven't done
much today so you only have to go to the
village
and fix the siren check out
what the problem is supposed to be
you should be able to finish in no time
come to my office for payment and then
you can go home
look after yourself why you talk so
funny hey this is siren head origins
la la la i don't look where i'm driving
la la la
what the hell is that la la la la
okay all right
i'm suddenly very slow there we go
flashlight shift to run e to interact
okay oh yeah the siren
i'm the perfect plumber for the siren
man you walk slow good god this is
oh my legs oh
someone was shot right here i should
stand
[Music]
hello sir damn thing working
all right
so people reported these weird noises
around the area and i don't think these
sounds are coming from random speakers
in the forest
i think the siren is the main problem
here it could be broken
i've been working here a very long time
and i've never encountered anything like
this
so boss could you send someone to fix
the damn siren
please and thank you you got it thanks
for calling me boss
thanks for remembering who's really in
charge here okay
he sent a plumber but it already took
him a day for him to arrive
according to the boss the guy's name is
sam which reminds me of a good friend
from college
well at least his name made my boring
day a little bit better
i'm glad my name could provide so much
joy to you i'd like to think most people
think of me that way
just had to make another audio log when
is this guy gonna arrive
it's already been two hours and i don't
see anyone coming
the siren keeps getting louder i'm
trying to do something about it but
nothing's working
ah [ __ ] now i got a headache look this
guy needs to hurry up and get here
all right well i have no idea what
happened there hmm this blood doesn't
tell me a goddamn
thing these bricks are all blown out
from the outside
in what could have happened here i
better walk slower to
think about it properly hmm
someone spilled ketchup someone's
carelessly eating
french fries here and then died
explosively
of flavor so i still don't know why they
sent a plumber
to fix a siren i don't know if a siren
is
plumberly motivated maybe it's a
situation like they send mario to fix
all the problems in mushroom kingdom
and he's technically a plumber so he
shouldn't be able to fix all of them but
occasionally there's a pipe that needs
to be laid
in princess peach's castle hello
ain't he
tim what does that say hemp
t tom need more
tom need more who god damn it get tom
some stuff
tom need more oh my god i read i'm
very nearsighted i saw this thing tore
the poor guy apart
i don't think the police can handle this
so i have to figure it out myself
if you're reading this run away from
this place
okay i'll run away i will run
i will run thank goodness there's no
stamina bar if i had to walk like
this slow i would lose my marbles
high glow light this is a job for a
plumber
damn the generator's out of gas oh i
know where i saw gas
i know i know where i saw gas oh these
bushes are
too thick i couldn't possibly walk
through there
[Music]
okay all right yeah i get it i get the
picture i get the picture oh
hey buddy hey whoa hey
someone's a little grumbly all right
hey it's lit up for me this gas
is lit this is usually a problem do i
need to worry about that or can i go
charging back to the generator and flood
it full of gas and
pump it to the brim use my plumbing
skills
seems like it was a whole lot of nothing
seems like there's nothing to actually
worry about over here i almost made this
too easy
ah what did i just see
well that was quick and quiet and bloody
i don't know why i must have caught like
a
rabbit or something in the in the in the
skoosh
hello i nee
i need to keep them you need to keep
them white
oh my god oh my god oh my god
i don't know if there was something
important that i needed to listen to but
i couldn't listen to that for even a
second longer oh my god
the note said something about keep
getting these weird radio messages
yeah me too yeah it's a bit of a problem
yeah i don't know why either
[Music]
that's fine
it's the hash slinging slasher hello yo
where are you going blah blah where are
you going blah blah
oh my god oh my god i can't read that
okay hey folks that dude who deals with
the siren must have gone crazy
this thing will never stop i'm gonna ask
this guy what's wrong with him
hey what's what the hell is wrong with
you
what's wrong with you i need to feed him
oh
feed him i thought you said keep him
oh i'm free must have listened to my
assertive
dominant alpha voice is that the hash
slinging slasher again
also there's a lot of wasted meat hey
you get
oh end of time get over here
hey i see you what's wrong with you well
that wasn't so bad
that wasn't bad it wasn't bad it's a
little rough around the edges and it
looks a little
unpolished but it had some good moments
i liked it it's a little clunky that's
all i could say about it
not bad not bad
[Music]
c are three scary games with four scary
games
and no jump scare it's just a nice
experience
from start to finish now i'll leave you
with lixian
close out this video he's around here
somewhere
i'm sure he'll find you don't worry he
won't scare you
he's nice like that all right i'll see
you around
[Music]
you